[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker cbs westwood 1 color analyst
host of the ross tucker football podcast
what options do you think the nfl had
with calvin ridley ross
not many dan
i mean
it's something that they talk about
often even back when i played
when it wasn't legal in united states to
bet on nfl games
it's all over the locker room i mean
both in the stadium
and at the practice facility it's one of
the first things they tell you at the
start of training camp every year
they are very clear that you can not
only can you not bet
on nfl games
you can't be associated with people that
bet on nfl games they know that you
can't be giving your buddies tips and
things like that
i think they had to suspend him for a
year i think they did the right thing
but can you see i'm trying to see his
side of things so when he does his
appeal
and i guess he's got three days to do
that
is there any wiggle room do you think
for him to say look i wasn't playing i
didn't go to a bookie i i didn't bet
against my team i only bet fifteen
hundred dollars i wasn't trying to hide
can you can you see the commissioner
listening to this going
okay
i'm going to change your suspension
you know what's interesting about that
dan it seems like over the years
that if you're honest with godel
that goes a long way with him i got to
be honest i'm not sure who exactly hears
the appeal
so i'd be curious to see who that is if
it does go to the commissioner because
it's discipline
i it would go to goodell
and if people are just open with him and
forthright
that does seem to give him a little bit
of leniency i just think
with the explosion of legalized sports
bet in the united states
it's going to be tough
for them to reduce this punishment i
think that they feel like they need to
send a very strong message to the other
2 000 nfl players
how gambling come up when you play
you know what's funny dan the only two
times it ever came up
were my first game in college
and my last game in the nfl if you can
believe that i'll never forget dan i'm
18 years old
i'm playing for princeton
we're playing cornell
i'm a freshman it's the season opener
i'm on the punt team
and the field goal extra point team
and i don't know why but maybe it's
probably for the wall street guys but
back then they would have the ivy league
lines would be in the newspaper
and this is 1997. my dad calls me that
week dan and he says hey ross
if i give you a signal in the fourth
quarter let cornell block the punt
obviously he was joking but it was kind
of crazy to think
i'm 18 i just had the prom three months
ago and there are people actually
wagering money on this like what if i
tripped or missed this block it was kind
of an eye-opening thing my dad was
joking but it was still funny and then
the last one dan is unbelievable
my career ended with a neck injury
against the ravens and for for
washington in 2007. so i'm on injured
reserve okay
which means you get paid for the whole
year but i knew i was retiring i knew i
had a herniated disc in my neck and
bruised my spinal cord i knew i was on
so i didn't go to any games or anything
but you get paid
so picture this dan it's week 17 last
week of the regular season
my wife and i and all my high school
buddies we go to my one buddies house in
charleston south carolina it's new
year's eve we're going to have a big
night
and the cowboys are playing washington
if washington wins
they make the playoffs
if they lose they're out so if
washington wins i get 18 000
so it's about 30 minutes until the game
starts and i tell my buddies and now
remember i'm from reading pennsylvania i
tell my buddies hey if if washington
wins i get 18 000
three of them pick up their phone
they're like
let me call my bookie you gotta put nine
thousand on the cowboys right now
gotta head you gotta put nine thousand
on the calendar
i'm not doing that i will say this
though dan
watching a football game
where you have 18 000
riding on it
having beers with your buddies i have
never been more into a football game in
my whole life i mean it was unbelievable
washington won
we made the playoffs i knew i was
getting the 18 grand i paid for
everything that night for new year's eve
it was epic
uh we're talking to ross tucker uh the
meat head james van der beek by the way
james van der beek turns 45 today
the actual james van der beek you turned
43 last wednesday so i don't know if
you've ever crossed paths with the actor
james van der beek you could play his
little brother in a movie
uh well little but bigger brother
no we haven't crossed paths one time
when i was filling in for you
fritzy
uh got him booked
and then he cancelled it and i think
it's i think it's because of what i said
about him
on the show i i think on the show we
were talking about dawson's creek
and i just thought he was a little bit
of uh i thought he was a little bit
too soft on dawson's creek okay
or even to be honest with you i thought
his priorities were all screwed up on
um in that movie well wait what's softer
acting in dawson's creek or watching
dawson's creek
oh i watched dawson's creek every
episode i would get dealing with the
girls in college it was me and like 12
girls watching dawson's creek it was
amazing but in dawson's creek he was
always like oh joey why don't you love
me so i didn't like that and then
varsity blues he's starting high school
football in west texas and he's caring
about academics and trying to get into
brown
he needs to focus on what matters and
what oh and the girl with the whipped
cream comes in and he does nothing with
it she's got whip oh she's only wearing
whipped cream he does nothing i am
convinced van der beek heard me talking
crap on his characters on your show and
cancelled on fritzy as a result and
those are all fair points was it ali
larter i like how you say it like you
don't know yeah yeah the the
whipped cream girl all right we have a
aaron rodgers bet where aaron is going
to end up
you got to decide today where does aaron
rodgers stay
go broncos steelers titans retirement
other
yeah
man i'm gonna go
i'm gonna ultimately say green bay okay
um i think
my hesitation
is because if it was green bay
you you would think that he would have
already said that by now
but there's been enough talk i've seen
of leflore
meeting with aaron rodgers agent
and david don his agent talking with
russ ball from the packers i guess i
don't understand
why your agent
would be spending that much time
talking contract
with the team
if you were planning to leave that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
and i think all these reports about him
being torn or whatever are just a way to
get
more favorable contract terms or more
money or more leverage whatever he's
looking for i don't know i'm going to
say he stays in green bay
yeah it feels like they're giving him
everything that he wants they're
bringing back his old quarterback coach
tom clements
it felt like green bay is going to
release this information of hey this is
sources this is this is going to change
the quarterbacking market salary wise
that doesn't get out unless you feel
like maybe aaron is not going to come
back and we did everything we could to
keep him
it's a fair point it feels like most of
the reports that have come out have been
from the packers side it's not like
aaron rodgers camp would be leaking that
you know he's been offered 50 million or
they're going to make him the highest
paid guy you know that doesn't really
help aaron's
image if the belief is that this is
about money i think most people want to
believe at least that this is not about
money it's about him going where he has
the best chance to win the super bowl
which i by the way i don't know how you
argue that that's denver over green bay
i think that's a tough argument to make
especially in the afc yeah over the nfc
i just think he's having a tough time
realizing what brady did last year
what stafford did this year and not
thinking that maybe he also needs that
change of scenery to get another one
yeah i think that's a fair point as well
we have a draft bet quarterback draft
bet we haven't talked to you since we
made it paulie has a bet
that he thinks a quarterback goes in the
first 13 picks
this year
and the over under set at 13 and a half
are you with paulie
first 13 picks we have a quarterback
selected or are you gonna take the over
i'm with paulie i'm gonna go the under
on that
i think
you know it's tough obviously because we
haven't gotten to free agency yet or
seen what happened with any type of
trade market
but i i think washington ends up taking
a quarterback at 11 if they don't get a
guy and i don't know that they're going
to get somebody else i mean there's just
not that many guys available
and washington has evidently called
everybody already literally they called
the chiefs about mahomes which is
amazing that would be great content by
the way to have that conversation be
videoed when they ask if mahomes is
available for trade yeah i just don't
know washington's going to be able to
get a veteran that they're happy with
and i think at 11
they'll probably end up taking one of
these kids so i'll go with paulie on the
under
you were uh joking about kenny pickett's
small hands
and um the fact that uh you know he
played outdoors played in pittsburgh how
did that go over on twitter
dan
it is remarkable
how much people
cannot sense sarcasm
on twitter i mean
but can we come out
ross how about sarcasm font
like you know that if you write it this
way
in in cursive or whatever that you mean
to be sarcastic
yeah but that kind of ruins the fun you
know for a while i was i literally for
people who didn't see it my twitter is
at ross tucker nfl and i said kenny
pickett's hands are way too small for
him to be able to play in a cold weather
nfl city like pittsburgh
knowing by the way i live in
pennsylvania i'm from pennsylvania i
know kenny pick it was just a pit the
last five years it's a joke no i've gone
full spectrum on this dan
for a while i thought it was funny that
people were just this dense and that
like they didn't get the joke
but now it's actually a poor reflection
on me
like these people either don't know who
i am
or they think i'm that stupid
it's not funny anymore don't laugh dude
i'm not funny i'm not i'm sorry i'm
sorry
oh
we actually had a hand measurement size
uh here on the show
i heard i can't believe
marvin
has the smallest hands yeah marvin
marvin's like six two probably 220
and uh he has very very small delicate
hands
i'm shocked guess what this is gonna
surprise you i don't have very big hands
either
i think i used to wear like an xl glove
because when you're wearing gloves as
alignment or really any player you want
it to be as tight as possible like you
almost want to be painted on you don't
want there to be any extra fabric at all
because you want to feel like you're not
wearing gloves
even though you are
i i actually have short arms
and small hands
those are my two worst qualities but i
have a huge head
and a crazy torso i'm basically like a
real life mr potato head like it just
doesn't make sense watch look how big my
head is yeah now i can't put like a
watch
my head is way bigger than my hand
look at that yes it is way bigger than
my face yes it is
yes it is i don't have very and it was
an issue like if the way i will say this
if the weather wasn't good and i was
playing center like in buffalo or new
england
it's not easy it's not easy to grip the
ball like there is something to that
yeah we don't make a big deal out of
wide receivers hands or the center's
hands
but we do make a big deal out of the
quarterback's hands
it's an issue for centers
not as much of one
as quarterbacks obviously you're not
controlling the ball you're not throwing
the ball people i mean dan by the way
you should see that tweet people hit me
back with the exact temperature of every
game he played for in pittsburgh people
were telling me that there was four
games the steelers played after pitt's
last game in december and january where
the temperatures fell below i mean
people take this stuff
we realize this is football right like
this is fun he's a good quarterback like
people take some of this stuff
way
way too seriously that's why we love
having you on ross thanks for uh joining
us as always
of course see you guys that's meathead
james van der beek ross tucker ross
tucker football podcast also even money
podcast you can find him on social media
at ross tucker nfl